E
HE'S HATEFUL?
WE'LL DISCUSS THIS LATER IN THE
SHOW.
>> FROM TEXAS FILLED WITH
MIGRANTS ARRIVING IN WASHINGTON
D.C. THIS MORNING, TEN MIGRANTS
DROPPED OFF AT THE CAPITOL HILL,
THIS PART OF GOVERNOR GREG
ABBOTT'S PLAN TO GET WASHINGTON
TO MAKE ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BETTER
MOVE BACK BECAUSE THE NUMBER OF
BORDER ENCOUNTERS SINCE BIDEN
TOOK OFFICE HITTING HEIST MARCH
WITH 221,303 ENCOUNTERS AND
TITLE 42 SET TO EXPIRE IN 37
DAYS.
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN ONCE IT'S
GONE?
MORE ARE EXPECTED TO CROSS AND
SOME COULD BE FLOWN TO NEW YORK.
THESE PHOTOS RELEASED YESTERDAY
SHOWING MIGRANTS TOUCHING DOWN
AT THE WESTCHESTER COUNTY
AIRPORT NORTH OF NEW YORK CITY
BEFORE WARNING BUSES AND HEADING
OFF INTO THE NIGHT.
THIS ROUTE WAS GROUNDED SOMETIME
AFTER A VIDEO WAS RELEASED LAST
FALL EXPOSING THE OPERATION WITH
ONE CONTRACTOR SAYING WAS ON
THEY'RE DOWN LOW BUT CLEARLY
IT'S BACK UP AND RUNNING.
LET'S GET TO IT, DAVID, TITLE 42
IS SET TO GO AWAY, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION CLEARLY NOT
LISTENING TO OTHER DEMOCRATS
WARNING THINGS WILL GET WORSE
ESPECIALLY INTO THE WARMER
MONTHS.
>> AND OF THOSE DEMOCRATS ARE
PROTECTING THEIR SEATS IN
CONGRESS OR THE SENATE.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
ISSUES, IF THEY DID, THEY WOULD
HAVE DONE SOMETHING OVER THE
DECADES AND NOTHING HAS BEEN
DONE ABOUT THIS.
SOMETHING WE NEED TO PAY
ATTENTION TO WOULD RESUME
FLIGHTS, THE ORGANIZATIONS
INVOLVED HERE, YOU GOT THE
LARGEST GOVERNMENT CONTRACTOR
AND A HUGE OPERATION AT MIAMI
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT AND THEY
ARE OPERATORS FOR THE GOVERNMENT
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY ALONG WITH
OTHER CONTRACTORS.
ALSO WITH EASTER WEEKEND, A LOT
OF PEOPLE ARE GOING TO CHURCH,
LUTHERAN CHURCH HEAVILY
INVOLVED, CHARITIES HEAVILY
INVOLVED IN OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE OUT OF AUSTIN TEXAS, TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, START ASKING
THE ELECTION, ALSO OF YOUR
CHURCH LEADERS WHY THE CHURCHES
ARE INVOLVED AND BASICALLY HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, THERE'S NO WAY
OTHER TO PUT IT.
THE NUMBER OF INTRODUCTIONS,
WHAT WILL HAPPEN WITH THE
OPERATIONS, 73000 AND ALL THE
OTHER INTRODUCTIONS AND THEN YOU
HAVE THE GETAWAYS?
WE SEE HUMAN TRAFFICKING, CHILD
TRAFFICKING, WOMEN BEING ABUSED,
TALK ABOUT THE ISSUES THAT ARE
THERE, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED
TO HAVE THE PEOPLE THAT CAN
REACH.
>> THE FORMER ACTING DHS
SECRETARY ADDRESSED EXACTLY WHAT
DAVID IS TALKING ABOUT.
>> THE ROOTS THAT THE CARTEL
USES AND REMEMBER WHO MANAGES
THE BORDER, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
THE DRUG CARTEL OF MEXICO, THEY
RUN EITHER HUMAN SMUGGLING
OPERATION THROUGH THE SAME
CHANNELS THEY RUN THEIR DRUG
SMUGGLING OPERATION, SOME
ESTIMATES THE DRUG CARTEL ARE
MAKING MORE MONEY FROM HUMAN
SMUGGLING AND DRUG SMUGGLING.
NO ONE, FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OR
STATE INCLUDING TEXAS IS DOING
ANYTHING TO STOP THAT.
>> NICOLE, THIS IS A MULTI
LAYERED CRISIS DOWN THERE.
>> ABSOLUTELY IN MY HOME STATE
IS ARIZONA ALONG THE SOUTHWEST
BORDER AND MY MOTHER IS THE
DIRECTOR FOR HOMES, THAT
PROVIDES THERAPY AND HOUSING FOR
THE SMUGGLING VICTIMS BUT THE
EPIDEMIC OF AMERICANS HYPOCRISY
WHAT'S GOING ON RIGHT NOW, THEY
CONTINUE TO SPEND BILLIONS WORTH
OF AID TO FOREIGN NATIONS, EVEN
ACROSS OCEANS BUT AT THE SAME
TIME WE ARE REMOVING THINGS IN
PLACE FOR OUR OWN ILLEGAL
CROSSING.
CHILDREN HAVE SUFFERED
THROUGHOUT COVID.
A LOT OF IT IS FENTANYL AND
OVERDOSE BECAUSE THEY ARE OFF
THE STREET, PLACE WITH ILLEGAL
FENTANYL, MUCH COMING THROUGH
THE SOUTHWEST BORDER AND DIE.
I CAN TELL YOU TITLE 42 WAS
ENACTED, 1942 PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY LAW PUT IN PLACE TO
DECREASE THE AMOUNT OF
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES.
WELL, OVERDOSE DEATHS AND IN
GENERAL, PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS,
WE NEED TO STOP ONLY THINKING OF
COVID, STOP THE VIRUSES THAT CAN
BE TRANSMITTED.
WHAT ABOUT CHILDREN DYING EVERY
SINGLE DAY?
MORE CHILDREN AND YOUNG ADULTS
HAVE DIED FROM OVERDOSES THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS THEN OF
COVID, LET'S KEEP THAT IN
PERSPECTIVE.
>> ABSOLUTELY, ABSOLUTELY
HEARTBREAKING AS WELL.
OUR OWN LAWRENCE JONES HAS BEEN
DOWN TO THE BORDER MULTIPLE
TIMES MOST RECENTLY TALKING WITH
MIGRANTS AT THE BORDER.
>> WHERE DOES HE COME FROM?
HOW LONG HAVE YOU BEEN ON THE
ROAD?
A WEEK?
YOU JUST GOT LOST?
WHEN YOU GOT TO AMERICA, WHO ARE
YOU GOING TO STAY WITH?
>> WE NEED TO FIGURE IT OUT
BECAUSE IT'S DIFFICULT.
>> YOU CAN WATCH THE REST OF HIS
TRIP TO THE BORDER, LAWRENCE
JONES CROSS COUNTRY 10:00 P.M.
EASTERN, WATCH OUT FOR THAT BUT
CAN I GET YOUR REACTION?
THIS IS ONE CONVERSATION, ONE
MOMENT ON THE BORDER.
>> SURE, MARIA BARTIROMO ON
FOXBUSINESS IS ALSO GOING DOWN
TO THE BORDER AND HAD SIMILAR
CONVERSATIONS LIKE THIS AND THEY
ARE ALL MILLER.
WE ARE LOOKING AT THE
POSSIBILITY OF ALMOST 5 MILLION
PEOPLE CROSSING THE U.S.
SOUTHERN BORDER ILLEGALLY, THE
FIRST TWO YEARS OF JOE BIDEN'S
PRESIDENCY ALONE.
IF THIS KEEPS UP, THERE'S NO
REASON TO BELIEVE WHY IT WON'T,
YOU HAVE A BORDER CZAR AND
KAMALA HARRIS, SHE DOESN'T EVEN
TALK ABOUT THIS ANYMORE.
THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF REFUSE TO
VISIT THE BORDER AHEAD OF THE
HOME AND SECURITY AND MAYORKAS
IS A BUFFOON CARRYING OUT A
POLITICAL AGENDA DOING NOTHING
TO PROTECT THE HOMELAND JOB.
THINK ABOUT THAT, WHAT IS 5
MILLION ILLEGAL MIGRANTS, WHAT
IS THAT?
YOU TAKE THE CITY OF DENVER, A
MAJOR CITY, ALL THE MAJOR
PROFESSIONAL SPORTS TEAMS,
MULTIPLY THEIR POPULATION, BY
SEVEN.
WE ARE NOW ON PACE FOR SEVEN
VENDORS TO OUR COUNTRY.
MEANWHILE AS NICOLE POINTS OUT,
OPIOID, FENTANYL IS THE LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH FOR THOSE BETWEEN
18 TO 49 IN THIS COUNTRY.
PRODUCED IN CHINA AND COMES
THROUGH MEXICO AND WE HAVE AN
ADMINISTRATION ALLOWING CITIZENS
TO BE KILLED AT AN ALARMING RATE
WHO WON'T DO ANYTHING BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T BENEFIT THEM
POLITICALLY.
IT IS A JOKE.
>> I WOULDN'T MIND DENVER, THEY
WERE EXACTLY LIKE THIS BUT I SEE
YOUR.THERE.
WHEN YOU START TALKING ABOUT THE
AMOUNT OF DRUGS COMING ACROSS,
NICOLE BRINGS UP FENTANYL CRISIS
WE ARE DEALI